Speaker 1: So you all know, of course, about
America first and the U.S. is the best and
we're the best country and we're the best
at everything and we have the best people
and we have the best everything.
And yet already Canada has surpassed the United
States in terms of the portion of adults who
have received a second or final dose.
Yeah, as I tweeted when this happened, quote,
You can buy I don't know if I need to quote
myself as David Pakman from the weekend.
You can buy all the vaccines you want early,
but if you're overrun with anti VAX Americans,
eventually Canada catches up.
And if you look at the vaccination curves
for each country, there's really a treasure
trove of information just in looking at the
shapes of these curves, which we're going
to put up on the screen for our video audience.
If you look at the US vaccination curve, you
see that it picks up in mid-March when we
had a lot of vaccines already.
And the trend is that as more and more vaccines
have become available into May, June, July,
where you can just walk in anywhere, no appointment,
get vaccinated.
The rate of vaccination in the U.S. has slowed
down in the United States because we so quickly
started hitting anti vaccine resistance from
people who don't want the vaccine.
Even though vaccine supply continues to go
up, the curve flattens and flattens to where
we are now, doing only about five hundred
thousand vaccine doses per day.
So the US story, as seen graphically here,
is tons of vaccines rapidly waning interest.
Now in Canada, the curve started almost flat
y well, because the U.S. had all the vaccines.
And as vaccine supply increased in Canada,
the vaccination curve went almost vertical.
And importantly, it is sustaining in this
way in the U.S. by the time we got to thirty
five, 40 percent doses, people vaccinated,
the curve was flattening.
Canada has surpassed us and is approaching
50 percent and it is sustained as an almost
vertical curve in a month.
Canada is in all likelihood going to be dramatically
more vaccinated than the United States.
So this anti back stuff is lethal.
If you are a Trampas who falsely believes
Trump made the vaccine, if you believe that,
why would you let Canada take all of the vaccine
protection from us?
This is I mean, this is such a dumb way to
see it.
But as I as I tweeted yesterday, maybe we
need to start marketing the vaccine to Trump
as a soda, like the way sodas are marketed
to people and call it Trump juice.
Is that what it will take?
But if you are a Trump, wouldn't you want
to honor your fearless leader who made the
vaccine by getting the vaccine that he made
for you instead of letting socialist communist
Marxist Canadians use it that remember, this
is all crazy.
I'm just thinking, how do we get Trump to
want it?
And the gap is is wild.
Canada is currently vaccinating about one
point two percent of its population daily.
One point two percent, the U.S. is fully vaccinating
zero point two percent of our population daily,
and it's not because we have a larger share
vaccinated, it's that Canada has surpassed
us now.
So this will soon end up being another complete
humiliation of the United States of America,
thanks to right wingers who are proud about
not getting vaccinated.
Now, it's fine to say Canada simply has fewer
people.
That's why we're talking about vaccination
per capita.
It is absolutely shameful that the United
States, with all the vaccines we have, is
struggling this badly to find people who want
to get vaccinated while the world is mostly
desperate for vaccines and actually getting
vaccinated as they get vaccines available.
These spikes we're seeing in the United States,
the masks already going back on in certain
places, expect more of it as people continue
to refuse to get vaccinated.
Now, I want to remind you, the good news continues
to be for now, the vaccines provide very good
protection against even the Delta variant.
If you're vaccinated and get sick, you're
very unlikely to be seriously ill, very unlikely
to be hospitalized.
There's places where, for example, at a certain
point last week, every hospitalized covid
patient in Los Angeles, California county
was not vaccinated.
That's fantastic.
But there will be breakthrough cases.
And remember, the slower we vaccinate, the
more those unvaccinated people can be vectors
for the development of variants for which
the vaccines are not well suited.
So this is a very real issue.
We're seeing it in the numbers.
We're seeing it in the numbers of what's happening
in other countries.
We're seeing it in the numbers of the spikes
that are taking place.
Some states, Florida, for example, just exploding
with cases and the hospitalizations are starting
to increase in mostly unvaccinated people.
If there's any good news.
And it's never great for me that people are
getting sick and dying.
But if there's any good news, it's that the
decision to get yourself vaccinated remains
a very good decision.
It's not 100 percent foolproof decision, but
it is very, very
good